bonjour eddie aït merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct ce matin sur la
beauté france on vient d'entendre
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement qui s'est rendu dans un
hôpital hier pour nous dire qu'il y
avait des hôpitaux au bord de la
saturation qu'à lui vous pensez de cette
opération de communication il prépare
les esprits à un confinement le week end
à paris selon vous va au delà de
l'opération de communication et de
présence sur le terrain il est clair que
les les chiffres de en région ile de
france ne se passe ne sont pas bons et
les communes augmentation régulière du
taux d'incidence donc on est assez
inquiet ou les élus locaux
je ne sais pas si cette opération avait
pour objectif de préparer les esprits
néanmoins il faut se préparer à prendre
de nos murs de nouvelles mesures qui
doivent être concertées bien sûr mais
qui doivent être aussi efficace après
cet échec de la stratégie vaccinale
elles sont a priori concertée puisque
anne hidalgo la maire de paris a été
consulté de la même façon valérie
pécresse la président de l'île de france
aussi a été concerté un confinement le
week-end pour l'île de france
je vais vous demander ce que vous en
pensez mais on va d'abord écouté jordan
bardella qui dit que c'est inhumain
c'est ce qu'avait dit également anne
hidalgo regarder il faut éviter ce
confinement y compris le week-end parce
qu'on voit bien qu'on arrive au bout
d'une logique avec le rythme actuel de
vaccination nous serions sortis
d'affaires on ou 2023 d'après kobe de
traqueur ce gouvernement a aussi raté
les commandes de vaccins vers les lieux
de tension et vers l'île de france in
une ans ce confinement le week-end qu'en
pensez vous oui mais c'est évident que
le principe du confinement reste assez
archaïque et brutal c'est quand même
méthode assez moyenâgeuses pour soigner
le mal néanmoins aujourd'hui face à une
stratégie vaccinale qui ne fonctionne
pas face à des français qu'ils sont
fatigués qui ont tendance à se relâcher
cela peut être une solution parler de
concertation tout à leur jeu
heureusement et il était temps que les
élus locaux et les collectivités
territoriales soient concertés pour une
approche différenciée par territoire ce
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent donc
on avance en avant serait tout ça est un
peu tardif
donc je crains malheureusement que
la situation nous oblige à de nouvelles
mesures de contrainte par un confinement
partiel le week-end qu'il faut tout
faire pour éviter un confinement
généralement je ne m'y opposerai pas un
compliment le week-end si celui ci
devait être décidée il faut qu'on fasse
tout vraiment pour éviter leur
confinement général on a l'impression
que ce confinement le week-end vient en
réponse au manque de vaccins emmanuel
macron a dit qu'il fallait attendre
encore quatre à six semaines
et vraisemblablement pour qu'on ait les
vaccins suffisant ça ressemble un petit
peu à la stratégie des masques en début
de l'épidémie quand on a confiné parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de masque finalement
c'est clair que tout ça n'est pas la
hauteur d'un pays comme comme le nôtre
ses hésitations ses tâtonnements 7
ce pilotage à vue de la problématique de
la crise sanitaire est une réalité et
une inquiète sur les territoires et il
nous désarme aussi nous les élus locaux
comme ceux que nous sommes interpellés
par des parts des administrés qui
veulent se faire vacciner qu'il n'y
arrive pas quand ils veulent comprendre
ce qu'il se passait et que nous n'avons
pas d'informations très clair il faut
quand même maintenant mieux communiquer
auprès des populations sur le calendrier
de la vaccination sur l'état réel de son
avance en aiguille on a l'impression que
ce reconfirme ans le week-end est là
pour éviter le pire le confinement
généralisée qui ne seraient plus ou
portable pour notre économie surtout
mais aussi et en particulier pour les
français qui sont aujourd'hui avoue
entre les dépressions le ras-le-bol est
une forme de désobéissance aujourd'hui
on n'a jamais vu autant de fêtes
clandestines de restaurants ouvrir comme
ça et donc on voit qu'on arrive au bout
d'un cycle et il ya une nécessité très
vite à restaurer de l'autorité d'abord
mais surtout de la confiance au bout du
tunnel grâce à la vaccination c'est ce
qu'a dit gabriel attal est ce que vous
comprenez la slovaquie ou la république
tchèque qui se tournent vers d'autres
pays que l'union européenne finalement
pour s'approvisionner en vaccins
en revanche là
servant de repère un écueil est une
stratégie européenne de vaccination de
masse chauffe pas bien au contraire et
qu'elles soient pas assez forte c'est
une et c'est une évidence aujourd'hui il
faut il faut trouver des solutions parce
qu'on parle de population on parle de
peuple aussi qu'ils doivent avoir
confiance dans leurs gouvernants et donc
je pense que la vaccination doit être
accélérée pour moi c'est une des
conditions à se re confinement le
week-end c'est qu'il va falloir
accélérer le rythme de la vaccination et
permettent aussi un renforcement des
aides
je pense notamment aux commerçants et
aux artisans qui vont devoir fermer mais
aussi à tous nos associations et nos
bénévoles qui n'ont plus pouvoir
pratiquer non plus pendant les week-ends
donc bon voilà la stratégie européenne
allait aller ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
moi je pense qu'il ya aussi une notion
importante aujourd'hui qui est celui de
la restauration de la confiance du
peuple avec ses gouvernants sur cette
gestion de crise qui est une épreuve et
des crises nous allons rencontrer
d'autres aujourd'hui on les entend
beaucoup dire
finalement même un confinement global de
3 semaines mais à l'issue on veut des
perspectives et notamment la réouverture
et le retour à une vie normale
les français veulent plus de clarté
selon vous ils ont raison de l'exigé
d'ailleurs on leur doit ce soit les élus
gouvernement leur doit plus de clarté
plus d'information plus de transparence
ça fait des mois que des associations
d'élus réclament des cartographies de
vaccination dans l'échelle des régions
que nous réclamons d'être associés aux
stratégies vaccinales tous à travers ça
se faire mais nous sommes très en retard
moi je faisais partie de ceux qui depuis
plusieurs mois militaire et je milite
toujours pour un passeport vaccinale
pour donner un cap aux françaises et aux
français qui seraient vaccinés qu'aurait
la chance d'avoir les deux doses qui
sont donnés actuellement et le vaccin
aujourd'hui on en a fait un problème on
en a fait la démonstration d'une
mauvaise gestion
alors que c'était une perspective
c'était un cap et une possibilité pour
retrouver une vie normale quel sentiment
de gâchis véritablement à travers
tj vote final n y at il pas une certaine
cacophonie des des élus finalement d'un
côté il ya ces vingt départements qui
risque d'avoir des mesures sanitaires
renforcés c'est la territorialisation la
nouvelle politique du gouvernement
d'ailleurs pour appréhender cette crise
a contrario vous allez l'entendre il ya
des élus qui demandent plus de souplesse
pour les les zones où finalement où le
virus circule moins c'est ce qu'a
demandé marc lefur notamment regarder à
cette heure-ci de la journée les
français pourraient prendre l'air ou
faire du sport
ce qui leur serait bénéfique moralement
et qui pourrait même contribuer à doper
leur immunité
dans ces circonstances le statu quo
n'est pas tenable
il en va du moral et de la santé
psychologique des français marc le fur
député à l'ère des côtes d'armor qui
demandait à ce que le couvre-feu 1 soit
repoussée à 19h au lieu de 18h est si
faible qu'il va falloir réfléchir à des
adaptations si vous confiner les gens le
week-end il faut peut-être adapter en
semaine l'horaire du couvre-feu mais il
faut surtout rendre acceptable les
mesures donc il faut faire un gros
travail de pédagogie qui n'est plus fait
aujourd'hui sa fille cadette alarmistes
sur la situation sanitaire ou visité des
hôpitaux il faut parler au peuple
français qui est un peuple adultes un
peuple responsable mais qui témoigne
quand il en a ras-le-bol là il le fait
néanmoins il a aussi conscience de sa
responsabilité dans la la chaîne de
vigilance pour se protéger du virus
étaient deux et de sa diffusion
évidemment s'il y avait ceux se se
confie non généralisée le week end il
faut l'adapter sur moi j'ai toujours
défendu une vision régionale pour être
efficace ça n'empêche pas d'avoir des
mesures territorialisée plus fort c'est
à dire est qu'en zone rurale
il faut agir de la même façon quand une
hyper dense et hyper peuple et je ne le
crois pas il faut faire des mesures de
bon sens comprise dans la population
pour qu'elle soit acceptée est donc
appliquée si le confinement ce week-end
est mis en oeuvre et qui n'est pas
appliquée
on assiste à une crise de l'autorité de
l'état ici je suis comme je l'expliqué
tellement pour une vision régionaliser
de l'action ça n'empêche pas que
l'autorité de l'état doit être
particulièrement présentes pendant cette
gestion de crise merci beaucoup et des
aït d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à
nos questions sur rt france